you can do this
ah lady Marjorie aren't you looking
lovely this evening Lord Tyrion your
grace with your permission allow me to
introduce lady mirror of house Forrester
your grace
the girl knows her courtesies impressive
you may rise house Forrester is a
northern house loyal to the king are
they I beg your pardon your grace I
wasn't talking to you I want to hear
from the girl is your family loyal to
the king perhaps you should ask the new
Lord Forrester he's not here is he she
is House forest as loyalty to the crown
never wavers your grace I see and yet
for centuries the Foresters have been
loyal bannermen to House Stark a house
of traitors they were the wardens of the
north we all served at the pleasure of
the king clever girl perhaps too clever
for her own good the girl did say that
Lori was unwavering she has a talent for
equivocation yet I question what she
really thinks is your house willing to
swear fealty to your new lead Lord Roose
Bolton
no doubt she's speechless in your
presence your grace old allegiances are
not easily abandoned but now that the
war is over we must look to rebuild and
forge new alliances there are ships and
shields to be built and Joffrey will
need a steady supply of iron wood for
his armies I'm told there are others who
would happily serve that purpose but I
trust we can rely on house Forrester
Forrester Ironwood does seem rather
unique yes your grace it would be
ashamed to see it fall into the hands of
another house I imagine you do almost
anything to prevent that from happening
wouldn't you ask any Lannister and they
do whatever was necessary to save
Casterly Rock it would be unfortunate to
see another house lay claim to what's
yours I won't dishonor myself your grace
I see
what would you have the girl do sir see
it's not as if she fought beside the
stocks wielding a battle axe for the
northern arm
you